YouTube might be best known for short
viral clips but you may not know that
YouTube also offers thousands of free
movies as well yes on YouTube you can
watch everything from indie films
uploaded by their creators to modern
movies released for free by major
studios to classic films that are now in
the public domain in fact there are so
many options it can be hard to know
where to start
that's why we've put together this list
of some of the best free movies on
YouTube kung fury this comedy action
indie was produced as a tribute to the
awesome action films of the 1980s in the
film of Miami detective is
simultaneously struck by lightning and
bitten by a Cobra which obviously gives
him superhuman kung fu powers game over
he uses the new power granted to him to
clean up the streets of Miami but our
hero faces his worst adversary yet when
he comes face-to-face with kung-fu
master Adolf Hitler Kapow Margot at the
wedding this dark comedy follows the
story of Margot and her son Claude as
they visit Margot sister Pauline for her
wedding to the unsuccessful artist and
musician Malcolm for me expectation just
trans to disappointment so ultimately
but the plot is secondary to the awesome
cast it features they call Kidman as
Margot Jennifer Jason Leigh as Pauline
and the hilarious performance from Jack
Black in the role of the unmotivated and
socially inept Malcolm it's a winner
four horsemen in this independent
British documentary the filmmakers take
a hard look at current banking and
economic practices in Western countries
as well as the war on terror and how it
all connects to our monetary policies
time Outland and critic Derek Adams
wrote instead of bombarding us with
sensational imagery and scare mongering
this competently narrated intelligibly
structured and cleverly illustrated film
presents this case fear a succession of
insights from a group of smart rational
orators in other words it's not exactly
a typical YouTube video slacker
not to be confused with the 2002 movie
slackers this 1991 independent
comedy-drama
marks the directorial debut of Richard
Linklater who would go on to direct
classics like boyhood and Dazed and
Confused
I love about these high school girls I
get older they stay the same a featuring
a uniquely unstructured storylines FLAC
is a slice of time a day in the life of
multiple twenty-something misfits as
they drift through Austin Texas shots
with a single 60 millimeter camera on a
micro budget of just $23,000 many
filmmakers including Kevin Smith have
cited slacker as a major source of
inspiration and the start of the 90s
independent movie movement the people
they need like scientists you heard
about that all the missing scientists
around the world and those that
mysteriously dying that's all part of
the recruiting process I really hope
your friend is not oh yeah they need a
lot of lackeys to do the labor though so
they'll be looking for ordinary guys you
know just like you and me funny about
love
while funny about love was pretty much
universally panned by critics upon his
release it might deserve a never look
why well it was directed by the
legendary Leonard Nimoy stars the late
great Gene Wilder and has an interesting
take on the whole a-ticking biological
clock troupe but from a man's
perspective while orders comedic genius
shines through in several places making
funny about love a good pick for a cheap
day/night flick
[Music]
Night of the Living Dead considered by
many to be the seminal zombie movie
Night of the Living Dead has been
massively influential on the horror
genre in the decade since its release
George a Romero's directorial debut is
more atmospheric than most modern zombie
movies focusing instead on the effects
of a zombie outbreak in a small town
with most of the film set within the
house where the cast members take refuge
Walking Dead's got nothing on this fire
nos fer a sue FW Murnau's 1922 silent
classic Nosferatu it's required watching
material for all horror fans the
earliest surviving example of a major
vampire film actor Max Schreck delivers
a mesmerizing performance as the ghastly
vampire in this unauthorized adaptation
of Bram Stoker's Dracula
it's amazing the movie even exists as a
course once ordered all copies to be
destroyed after Stoker's estate sued for
copyright infringement but loyal fans
secretly saved it and passed copies
around making it one of the first true
viral videos ever only fitting for the
original Bed Intruder so y'all need to
hide your kids hide your wife a hedgehog
because they rapin errbody out here
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which free
youtube film you'd recommend